[Music]
netflix recently announced that they'd
be raising their prices cutting content
canceling original shows and cracking
down on password sharing what's more is
that they actually lost subscribers this
past quarter for the first time in the
company's history so yeah netflix is in
trouble and this brings up an important
question will netflix be able to survive
the streaming wars and how on earth did
they even get themselves into this mess
to find out whether netflix will thrive
or die among the multitude of new
streaming services we'll first need to
understand how they even got here
netflix was founded by reed hastings and
mark randolph in 1997 as a mail-based
dvd rental service as the story goes
hastings was astonished when he received
a 40 late fee from blockbuster when he
returned his copy of apollo 13. he then
looked to his local gym which ran on a
subscription service and which he saw as
a much better business model as a huge
admirer of jeff bezos and amazon.com
hastings developed the idea to become
the amazon of movie rentals disrupting
the entertainment industry entirely
netflix.com was then launched as the
first dvd rental and sales site with
only 30 employees and 925 titles
available at the time soon after
hastings and randolph met with jeff
bezos where amazon.com offered to
acquire netflix for approximately 15
million dollars randolph was on board
because he feared amazon would just make
their own version of netflix if they
turned them down but hastings declined
asserting that netflix would be the
future of home entertainment and he was
pretty much right the company continued
to grow rapidly over the next few years
until the dot-com bubble when netflix
saw some hard times and hastings and
randolph offered to sell netflix to
blockbuster for 50 million dollars to
which the ceo of blockbuster actually
laughed
at the time blockbuster was thriving
bringing in over 300 million dollars per
year with its brick and mortar stores so
they saw no need to invest in a
struggling startup like netflix although
they did struggle netflix was able to
survive the bubble and the subsequent
decline in the stock market following
the september 11th attacks the company
went public on may 29 2002 selling 5.5
million shares of common stock at 15 per
share over the next several years
netflix saw tremendous growth outpacing
its brick and mortar competitors this
growth is likely due to hastings
insistence that netflix should focus on
the online portion of its model and the
company launched its online streaming
service in january of 2007. at the time
however they only had a thousand films
available for streaming compared to the
70 000 they had available for rent
by the year 2010 netflix was a
powerhouse for streaming and a dominant
player in the entertainment industry it
was this same year when blockbuster
declared bankruptcy and when netflix
acquired the rights to the television
series breaking bad many people
attribute blockbuster's demise to
netflix's sudden surge in popularity
because they're streaming rights to
shows like breaking bad but really they
fell apart because of a huge amount of
debt they had incurred and poor
management practices
throughout the 2010s netflix started to
expand its operations into other
countries and they started to gain the
rights to programming from large
companies such as warner bros the walt
disney company nickelodeon tnt and amc
when these contracts were signed netflix
realized the need to develop their own
original library before these companies
got wise and started making their own
streaming services they started
releasing original shows such as house
of cards oranges the new black bojack
horseman several joint productions with
marvel studios arrested development
narcos the crown and stranger things
stranger things could not have come at a
better time because other streaming
services were starting to gain traction
and becoming real competitors in the
streaming wars these companies such as
amazon prime video hulu hbo apple tv
plus and disney plus already had deep
libraries and stronger intellectual
properties which they could capitalize
on so as soon as their contracts expired
with netflix they could be the sole
streaming platform for their own content
the success of shows like stranger
things and house of cards were one of
the main reasons why netflix was able to
continue its growth through the mid to
late 2010s by 2020 though the company
was at a point where they seemed to be
green lighting almost any shows
resulting in a large amount of low
quality content being released most of
which went unwatched it was at this
point when the nightmare truly began
for the first time in the company's
history netflix lost subscribers in the
first quarter of 2022 they lost over 200
000 subscribers and it's expected that
they'll lose another 2 million over the
next quarter so why did this happen
where did they go wrong over the last
several months netflix has released a
slew of negative announcements including
the fact that they'd be raising their
prices while also canceling shows and
development and cutting out popular
content as their contracts expire with
other companies there have also been
rumors that the company's ceo reed
hastings is considering adding
advertisements to the platform when ads
have been nowhere to be found since the
company's beginning lastly netflix has
announced that they'll be cracking down
on password sharing which up to this
point has been more of a feature of the
platform rather than a loophole with
netflix even tweeting in 2017 love is
sharing a password
all of these events have led to a
dramatic decrease in subscribers layoffs
of almost 500 netflix employees and a
sharp fall in the company's stock price
the price per share went from 690 in
october of 2021 to just 175 dollars in
june of 2022 an almost 75 percent
decrease in the stock price in a matter
of months
if netflix hopes to survive this
downturn i believe that they need to do
three things focus on making quality
content only green light highly
marketable and merchandiseable shows and
change their release schedule let's
start with the first item though netflix
needs to focus on making quality content
alone not wasting time and resources on
all the small low quality shows that
have been greenlit over the past few
years the cost of making these shows has
gone up drastically meaning the shows
they decide to make have to be hits in
the past netflix hasn't done a very good
job of marketing their shows simply
because of a lack in the marketing
budget and because they've had too many
shows and not enough space to market
them properly on their platform if they
focus on making a smaller number of
shows it'll be easier to showcase each
of them ensuring no content is lost in
the current nightmare that is netflix
next they need to try to find new ideas
for programming that are more easily
merchandisable if you look at netflix's
most popular shows you won't find much
merchandise available online shows like
ozark the crown and bridgerton aren't
very merchandiseable and there are very
few people who would be willing to buy
merchandise for the shows even if it
were readily available for purchase
if you look at other streaming services
top shows though you'll see highly
merchandisable shows such as one
division and the mandalorian sales for
baby yoda merchandise alone have
probably been higher than the sales for
all of netflix's top shows put together
if netflix releases more highly
merchandisable shows such as their one
saving grace stranger things they'll be
able to unlock an entirely new revenue
stream and build a stronger community
around the netflix brand lastly if
netflix wants to survive they'll need to
change their release schedule currently
when netflix releases a new show they
drop all the episodes for the season on
the same day while many people enjoy
this it might actually be hurting the
company in the long run when people
binge shows they lose the sense of
wonder and enjoyment that comes when a
new episode is released each week almost
like a christmas morning effect every
week it also cuts out the room for
people to make rumors and theories about
their shows most of which ends up being
free word of mouth advertising if
netflix changed their release schedule
to once per week they wouldn't have to
make so much content either they'd be
saving money and retaining subscribers
for longer as they stay subscribed for
the duration of a show's entire release
schedule to see this in action let's
compare one of netflix's most popular
shows to one of disney pluses squid game
and obi-wan kenobi let's start with
squid game a south korean survival drama
which became netflix's most watched show
within a week of its launch every
episode was released on the same day and
the buzz surrounding the show lasted for
a couple of weeks the show provided a
pretty marketable concept but very
little room for merchandising besides
green sweatsuits and maybe masks with
the playstation buttons on them then you
look at obi-wan kenobi the star wars
mini-series following the character of
obi-wan kenobi which became disney
plus's most watched original series on
its opening weekend the series had a
weekly release schedule with two
episodes dropping on its premiere date
and one episode following each week
thereafter this left room for tons of
rumors and speculation about where the
show would be heading and the buzz
surrounding the series lasted for weeks
the character of obi-wan kenobi and his
story during this era of star wars
provides a highly marketable concept
with plenty of room for merchandising as
well
t-shirts lightsabers and tons of other
items have been sold in a frenzy over
the past several weeks far surpassing
any merchandise released for squid game
if netflix were able to take some of its
most popular tv concepts and position
them in a way that makes them more
marketable and merchandisable while also
spreading out their release schedule i
believe they'd see fantastic results
only by doing so will they be able to
survive the streaming wars and return
their share prices back to their former
status
also quit whining about password sharing
if someone's paying 15 or 20 bucks a
month they should be able to let their
roommates log in too
anyways if netflix hopes to survive this
nightmare they'll have to make some
pretty big changes but let me know what
you think should netflix start to
stretch its release schedules drop your
thoughts below also check out the video
on your screen for some different
content don't forget to like and
subscribe and thanks for watching rocket
riley
[Music]